focus on one thing in general rather
than lots of different things that
you're not sure about because if you're
starting out everything looks like an
opportunity but all of them won't work
unless you pick one because you have to
say no to all the other Mistresses and
then from there six figures is sell
something to someone so it's one Avatar
one product one channel just pick one
channel one media Source whether it's
Facebook Instagram YouTube Twitter
consistently start going on that whether
that's cold outbound whether that's
content whether it's running paid ads
and start reaching out to people there
to start selling your stuff